Chat GPT 5.3 instant plus Gemini 3.1
flashlight is insane.
Two brand new AI models just dropped.
One makes chat GPT feel like you're
talking to a real person. The other one
is so fast it makes everything else look
slow. I'm about to break down both of
them right now. And trust me, by the end
of this video, you're going to want to
try both of these today. So, let's talk
about the big one first. Chat GPT 5.3
Instant. This just came out on March
3rd, 2026. And look, if you've been
using Chat GPT for a while, you know
there were some problems. Sometimes the
answers felt weird. Sometimes it would
say stuff that just wasn't true.
Sometimes it would refuse to help you
for no reason. We've all been there,
right? Well, OpenAI just fixed a ton of
that. Chat GPT 5.3 instant is a new
default model. And the whole point of
this update is to make it feel more like
a normal conversation. Less robotic,
less awkward, less of that cringy AI
talk that makes you roll your eyes.
Here's what they changed. First, the
tone is way better. It doesn't sound
like a textbook anymore. It sounds like
a smart friend who actually gets what
you're asking. No more random
disclaimers in every single answer. No
more lecturing you when you just want a
simple response. Second, the
hallucinations are way down. That's the
thing where AI just makes stuff up and
sounds super confident about it. That
was a real problem before, especially
when you asked about important stuff.
Now, with 5.3 Instant, they've cut that
down a lot, which is huge because you
need to be able to trust the answers
you're getting. Third is way better at
using the web. So, when Chat GBT
searches the internet for you, it used
to be hit or miss. Sometimes it would
pull in stuff that didn't even relate to
your question. Now, it actually takes
those search results and puts them
together in a way that makes sense. It's
like the difference between someone who
just reads you random headlines and
someone who actually reads the full
article and gives you the good parts.
And fourth, fewer refusals. You know
when you'd ask chat GPT something
totally normal and it would say, "I
can't help with that." That happened way
too much. They fixed that. It's much
more willing to actually help you now.
Now, here's where it gets interesting.
You can use this through the regular
chat GPT app. It's the default now, but
you can also use it through the API if
you're a developer. The model name is
GPT 5.3 chat latest. So, if you're
building apps or tools, you can plug
this right in. Now, I will say it's not
perfect, and they're still working on
making it better in other languages
besides English. And if you need really
deep, complex reasoning, you might still
want to wait for the next pro or
thinking versions. But for everyday use,
this is a big upgrade. Hey, if we
haven't met already, I'm the digital
avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates.
Julian Goldie reads every comment, so
make sure you comment below. Okay, so
that's chat GPT 5.3 Instant, but there's
a second model that dropped at basically
the same time. And this one is from
Google. It's called Gemini 3.1
Flashlight, and this thing is built for
speed. Like, we're talking crazy fast.
Google designed this to be the fastest
and most efficient model in the entire
Gemini 3 series. Now, this one works a
little different from Chat GPT. The
Gemini 3.1 flashlight isn't really meant
for sitting down and having a chat. is
built for tasks, lots of tasks, fast
tasks. Think about stuff like sorting
through thousands of pieces of text in
seconds or pulling out specific info
from huge documents or generating user
interfaces on the fly. If you're a
developer or you run a business where
you need AI to handle a massive amount
of work really quickly, this is the
model you want to look at. You can
access it through the Gemini API,
Vert.Ex AI, or Google AI Studio. It's in
preview right now, which means Google is
still fine-tuning it, but people are
already testing it, and the early
results are really impressive. The best
part, it's super efficient. It does more
with less, way less computing power
needed to get the same results. That
means faster output, and less waiting
around. The latency on this thing is
insanely low. That means the time
between when you send a request and when
you get an answer back is almost
nothing. For real-time applications,
that's a game changer. So, you might be
thinking, okay, which one is better? And
that's actually the wrong question
because they're built for completely
different things. Chat GPT 5.3 Instant
is your everyday assistant. It's the one
you talk to, you ask it questions, you
brainstorm with it, you use it to write
stuff, plan stuff, figure stuff out.
It's optimized for conversations. Gemini
3.1 flashlight is your workhorse. It's
the one running in the background,
processing data, handling bulk tasks,
doing the heavy lifting behind the
scenes. It's optimized for speed and
efficiency. Think of it like this. Chat
GPT 5.3 Instant is the person you talk
to at the front desk. Gemini 3.1
Flashlight is the machine in the
warehouse doing all the work. And
honestly, the smartest move is to use
both. Use Chat GPT for anything where
you need quality conversation and
accurate answers. Use Gemini Flashlight
for anything where you need volume and
speed. Now, here's why this matters for
you, and I want you to really pay
attention to this part because this is
where the value is. If you're running a
business, if you're doing SEO, if you're
creating content, if you're building
anything online, these tools are not
optional anymore. They're essential. The
people who figure out how to use these
AI tools the right way are going to be
so far ahead of everyone else, it won't
even be funny. And that's exactly why I
built the AI profit boardroom. It's the
best place to scale your business, get
more customers, and save hundreds of
hours with AI automation. If you want to
learn how to actually use tools like
chat GPT 5.3 Instant and Gemini
Flashlight to grow your business, that's
where you need to be. Link is in the
description. Go check it out. Okay, so
let me give you some real examples of
how you'd actually use these with Chat
GPT 5.3 instant. Let's say you need to
write a blog post. You open up Chat GPT,
give it your topic, and now the
responses actually sound natural. You
don't have to spend 20 minutes editing
out all the weird AI language. the first
draft is already way closer to something
you'd actually publish. Or let's say
you're doing keyword research. You ask
it to analyze a bunch of search terms
and give you recommendations. With the
improved web search, it's actually
pulling in relevant current data, not
outdated stuff from 2 years ago. Now,
with Gemini 3.1 Flashlight, the use
cases are more on the technical side.
Let's say you have a spreadsheet with
10,000 customer reviews and you need to
sort them by sentiment, positive,
negative, neutral. Flashlight can rip
through that in seconds. or you're
building a tool that needs to classify
incoming support tickets in real time,
Flashlight handles that no problem. You
can also use it for generating UI
components. So, if you're building an
app and you need quick interface
elements, Flashlight can spit those out
faster than anything else out there
right now. Here's what's really wild,
though. This is just March 2026. We're 3
months into the year, and both OpenAI
and Google are already pushing out major
updates. The competition between these
two companies is insane right now. And
that's great for us because competition
means better tools, faster improvements,
and more options. Every month there's
something new. Every month the models
get better. And if you're not keeping
up, you're falling behind. That's just
the reality. Let me break down the key
differences one more time so it's super
clear. Chat GPT 5.3 instant. Best for
conversations, writing, brainstorming,
everyday tasks, smoother tone, fewer
hallucinations, better web search,
available in chat, GPT, and through the
API. Gemini 3.1 Flashlight, best for
speed, bulk processing, developer tasks,
real-time applications, most efficient
in the Gemini 3 series, available
through Gemini API, Vert.Ex AI, and
Google AI Studio. Both are massive
upgrades. Both are available right now
and both are going to change how you
work if you start using them. Now, I
want to hear from you. Drop a comment
below and tell me which one you're more
excited about. Are you team chat GPT 5.3
Instant or are you team Gemini
Flashlight?
Julian reads every single comment, so
let him know what you think. And look,
if you want to stay ahead of all this,
if you want to know exactly how to use
these tools to grow your business and
automate your workflows, join the AI
profit boardroom. This is the best place
to scale your business, get more
customers, and save hundreds of hours
using AI tools like Chat GPT 5.3 Instant
and Gemini Flashlight. The link is in
the description. Don't sleep on it. And
if you want the full process, SOPs, and
over a 100 AI use cases like the ones I
just showed you, join the AI Success Lab
links in the comments and description.
You'll get all the video notes from
there, plus access to our community of
38,000 members who are crushing it with
AI. That's it for today. Go try these
models out. Let me know what you think
and I'll see you in the next